what it's happened to reject nation it's
Greg Alec here and it's John Humphrey
over here so with comic-con going on
there is a trend that released that a
lot of subscribers are saying we have to
watch is required a because eco who
Wyatt's or however you pronounce it is
in this trailer alongside on box Tony
Jaa and Michael Jai White Michael J
Wyatt he's badass too from my
understanding this is an American film
[Music]
job
well I want to fight
how ya find them we kill them no messing
about
damn ah
[Music]
and it's a full-on action cast here dude
[Music]
that's awesome
Wow hey excited for this man I'm glad
for this yeah I mean the work I'm most
familiar with is Tony Johnny Eko wise
the other actors I've seen in other
stuff before I'm not as familiar with
their stuff and you know Michael Jai
White who I finish arrow and I know he
has a reoccurring character in arrow he
can really kick some serious butt talk
that's for sure but he also in the movie
called I you see and you know a bunch of
other stuff Universal Soldier is a
return I remember that they know the
first thing I saw and then with spawn
anyway yeah I mean this film does look
badass the one thing that you can count
on with these guys in their fight
choreography is that when they're
hitting each other they're really
getting hit you know
yeah nobody no one has died yet from
being interpreted but it really makes
you wonder how they capture and shoot
these things I mean it looks like
they're packing some punch even if some
of the footage is yet up or whatever it
seems like these users really beat each
other up
yeah it looks just like a
straightforward action thriller event or
you just want as many fight scenes as
possible here because that's what you
really care about when you see a trailer
for a movie like this but what they
don't show you in the trailer or at
least maybe I missed it but what I would
like is for Eko wise and Tony Jaa to
have a fight scene together even though
things like they're fighting
side-by-side in this movie I think it'd
be badass yeah with both of their
fighting styles combined oh dude yeah
man they really did do some crazy ass
flips and stunts and they really get hey
I'm just happy that we're seeing more
and more you know martial arts based on
movies I'm going back now you know miss
it yeah especially since it seems like
you know the raid kind of helped
revitalize things and also you know
mixed martial arts is really huge now I
feel like we've got a nice opportunity
to bring this back into yeah more more
prevalence in cinema when we were
growing up it was like Jackie Chan
you and be out on Sammo hung and now we
go simply and gently nowadays we have
like Tony Jaa Kiko wise Don en white and
onions or anybody you can't get here we
won now this is really exciting actually
little badass I you know as a trailer I
could have used maybe a little bit more
of like okay this is what are they
fighting about
yeah even when we get these American
films where they are doing fight scenes
well I'll talk to you have a hard time
seeing what's going on I think it's why
we appreciate films like John wick or
even a trailer for atomic blonde you're
like oh you could actually see the fight
that's going on yeah here you can really
see like they even slow down the frame
rate so you can be like oh look at them
flipping through tons before landing at
Cana yeah
well this looks like an actual martial
arts movie you know it doesn't look like
an American action movie the features
it's like a Saw movie that really knows
who is upping poop that's it yeah yeah
yeah yeah totally I believe that man the
director has a lot a ton of stunt
experience and I can definitely see that
for something like this well thank God
to recommend a shredder this is a nice
treat well you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow that John Humphrey at Daniel
Humphrey and check out our exclusive
perks Awards over at patreon.com plus
buddy reject access act